[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui didier
van cauwelaert pour l'inconnu du 17 mars
c'est le premier roman à se dérouler
pendant le confinement charles berberian
pour son album une époque fantastique
il y a également clarisse kaplan qui
joue joséphine baker dans joséphine b
une biographie théâtrale de la première
femme noire à être devenu une star en
france c'était en 1925 et jean marc
fuentes le directeur du festival des
voix des lieux des mondes qui se déroule
du 8 au 11 octobre à -11 assez à la
française à bois sac et à la française
mais commençons tout de suite par notre
époque qu'est ce qui caractérise ce
début de xxième siècle à part les
masques est leur réponse de clarisse
kaplan votre image
elle a un siècle à peu près 1
pourquoi avoir choisi celle ci haut je
trouve que ça correspond bien à l'époque
l'incertitude dans laquelle nous sommes
dans la crise sanitaire économique
écologique on avance pas à pas sur le
fil du rasoir on sait pas trop à quelle
sauce on va être mangé et puis c'était
un petit hommage à charles chaplin que
j'apprécie et que j'admire infiniment
entre chaque film et je sais pas dans
quel film on pourrait croire que c'est
dans le cirque mais c'est pas le cirque
le cirque il a fait bien plus de
talhouët alors c'est là c'est dans quel
film vous savez c'est si c'est le cercle
assez cirque 1928
ah oui le premier alors ouais oui oui
oui alors je confondais avec limelight
l'eifel un hommage à la gcc les feux de
la rampe qu'il a fait après la guerre
l'image de didier van cauwelaert va
apparaître derrière moi plus mystérieuse
il s'agit du test le plus fiable pour
identifier la présence
ducobu 19 est un chien est le premier à
première expérience concluante a eu lieu
pendant le confinement on a affrété un
eurostar pour transporter un plombier de
melun et sa chienne il a et sidi driss
hic le monsieur en question avait dressé
cette chienne a comme lui détecte et son
blues de détecter les fuites de gaz et
sa chienne le faisait beaucoup plus
rapidement que lui david distance
impressionnante même je vous allez
détester pour les cancers détectés les
textes concernant la prostate et de la
vessie et la une un laboratoire anglais
l'a fait venir est la tesla chienne a
passé les tests avec succès elle a très
vite reconnu parmi plusieurs
échantillons la molécule de co vite
qu'on lui avait fait respirer d'abord et
ensuite comme vous savez les suspects
qui sont derrière un mur il ya plusieurs
personnes et elle a identifié la
personne qui était porteur un porteur
sain mais comment il a expliqué massa se
développe partout comment explique-t-on
parce que en fait ça n'a pas d'odeur le
le le virus ben bien sûr que si pour un
chien pour nous non mais pour les chiens
capables de détecter
comme ils le font couramment aujourd'hui
dans les hôpitaux les cancers du sein de
la prostate de la vessie notamment avec
100 % de réussite
la différence des autres tests ils sont
capable de renifler explosif on a été
sauvé de nombreux attentats à paris
grâce à cette brigade canine de chiens
détecteurs d'explosifs y compris les
explosifs qu'on ne peut pas détecter
comme les dérivés de centex est tous
dans les moyens traditionnels et les
chiens détecte même l'épilepsie les
crises d'épilepsie avant même que les
symptômes soient soient détectables donc
le flair autres choses sont aussi les
ondes électromagnétiques en ce qui
concerne le ce qui se passe dans le
cerveau du patient et aujourd'hui voilà
on a dans plein d'endroits douze pays
ont demandé à hassi dit drissi donc ce
plombier de melun de venir tester les
chiens la russie notamment
et lui est ce que je remets revenue dans
sa réponse il a dit moi je préfère
rester mais je veux 6 hectares pour
mettre tout ça en oeuvre et que ce soit
la réinsertion de non qu'ils soient au
centre de tous les personnels que je
veux employés là dedans donc on peut
aussi avoir de très belles aventures sur
fond de kovy des de confinement comme je
raconte dans mon livre c'est vrai que ce
chien enfin un chien qui a ce pouvoir là
un rôle assez important dans le livre et
je pense qu'il est bon de rappeler dans
ces périodes anxiogène que les solutions
existent et qu'elles peuvent être aussi
apporté un émerveillement qui nous fait
du bien on parle de votre livre dans un
instant charles berberian votre image à
vous alors c'est un film mais lequel j
me c'est le prochain film de bruno
podalydès qui s'appelle les deux alfred
je venais de voir ce film quand vous
m'avez demandé de donner mon image qui
caractérise l'époque c'est un film de
légère anticipation et j'ai l'impression
qu'on vide dans le futur aujourd'hui
vraiment c'est à dire qu'on imaginait
1 les années 2000 2005 avec des voitures
en train de flotter dans les airs et en
fait on se rend compte que pas du tout
mais d'un autre côté tout ce qu'on est
en train de vivre en ce moment depuis
quelques temps on a l'impression que
c'est dans un bouquin de k dick quoi et
cette image
pour moi c'est celle aussi de la
fraternité ce que raconte aussi le film
non pas la fraternité entre bruno
podalydès qu'on voit sur les sur la
photo à droite et denis podalydès à
gauche c'est la fraternité choisie
c'est-à-dire dans le film ils sont pas
frères et ils deviennent une famille
d'une certaine manière avec sandrine
kiberlain qui joue le troisième rôle et
c'est une manière d'inventer une
nouvelle vie quand le futur nous pousse
à l'envisager
et j'ai l'impression qu'on est vraiment
dans cette situation aujourd'hui
comment imaginer réinventer nos vies
réinventer l'avenir qui nous semblent ne
pas vouloir exister ou se coucher quoi
jean marc fuentes directeur du festival
des voix des lieux et des mondes alors
une très très belle photo qui est prise
à l'endroit où a lieu le festival 1
exactement c'est une installation qui a
eu lieu en septembre pour l'ouverture du
pont la première période du festival et
j'ai voulu mettre en avant cette photo
dans le cloître de moissac et une
installation de l'art contemporain de la
lune
ç'a permis et aux gens de se croiser de
venir avec d'ailleurs en famille avec
les poussettes et tout et prendre des
photos et se retrouver et c'est vrai que
la vie est revenue
les gens sont croisés sont parlé ils ont
échangé il ont pris des photos
choquantes avec entre eux et ça c'est
vrai on s'est dit la vie est reparti
dans le quad dans un patrimoine de
moissac et avec cette installation de de
ce britannique qui qui installe
un peu partout 7,7 l'une ses élus que
jerman et voilà c'était un moment
émouvant et d'échangés qui nous dit mais
ça va repartir
voilà cette ligne n'est donc pas vrai
mais mais mais elle est belle comme la
vraie lune et bien commençons
[Musique]
didier van cauwelaert vous publiez donc
l'inconnu du 17 mars chez albin michel
le 17 mars c'était le jour du
confinement
je crois que c'est le seul roman de la
rentrée en tout cas un des rares qui
parle du confinement on s'attendait à ce
qu'un et beaucoup en faites pas il
fallait le temps de les écrire
avec cet événement quand même très
récent j'ai commencé à l'écrire la
veille du confinement
parce que je ne pouvais pas rester les
bras croisés
comme disait philip k.dick été cités
tout à l'heure il avait une phrase que
j'adore quand cette réalité ne vous
convient pas changé zan donc un
romancier là pour essayer de rendre la
réalité différent plus respirable
en tout cas c'est ce que j'essaie de
faire j'avais besoin d'un regard qui
nous raconte cette époque un peu
différemment et ce roman est née d'une
émotion j'ai eues dans la rue
un sdf qui tout à coup voyez qu'il était
observé différemment par les gens qui se
battent et de rentrer se terrer chez eux
avec leurs stocks de pâte et papier
toilette et tout à coup lui qui était au
soleil tranquille qui apparemment
avaient le droit de rester dehors été
regardée comme une sorte de privilégier
paradoxal il regardait un petit peu
qu'avec une jalousie préventive et aussi
parce que lui s'il était serein si leur
disais bon courage avec beaucoup de
sincérité c'est que c'est que lui
n'avait rien à perdre et ça n'allait pas
changer fondamentalement son existence
cette expérience inédite pour le reste
de la population
donc là je me suis dit j'ai mon
narrateur mais qui est cette personne
que faisait-il avant d'être là sur deux
sur le trottoir et que vas-tu lui
arriver au moment du confinement où tout
se referme
je voulais raconter une histoire
d'ouverture de reconstruction de
quelqu'un qui est devenu une sorte de
mobilier urbain et qui peut-être va se
voir confier une mission gigantesque en
relation avec avec ce virus qui change
la donne
humaine autour de lui alors ce sdf est
percuté par une voiture le 17 mars et il
se réveille dans cette voiture qui est
conduite par la jeune fille dont il
était amoureux quand il avait 18 ans et
c'est vrai que pendant le confinement ça
a été une période de retour en arrière
heures beaucoup de gens sur instagram
par exemple publier des photos de
enfants quand vous expliquer et vous
avez dû le ressentir puisque vous avez
cette idée disait vente comme l'
pourquoi est ce qu'on s'est mis à
revenir en arrière comme ça sur son
passé pendant ce confinement
d'abord parce que en effet l'avenir on
savait pas de quoi il serait fait
combien de temps dureraient ce cet
enfermement 7 cette privation de liberté
générale était terrible - pour les
écrivains et les artistes en général qui
sont quand même un peu habitués à se
couper du monde pour plonger dans une
oeuvre mais c'est leur choix c'est leur
liberté là c'est quand même différent
donc moi j'ai faim en écrivant 10 12h
pas avoir quinze heures par jour d'être
totalement libre de le faire c'était
purement mon choix et j'étais pas
reparti en arrière dans mon passé
j'étais au parti dans le passé de mon
personnage mais a passé qui grâce à ce
confinement allait se reconstruire se
régénérer
car ce garçon a eu un départ dans la vie
formidable il était le fils d gardien
d'une grande propriété par la forêt de
rambouillet et il est tombé amoureux fou
à 17 ans de la fille de la boulangerie
qui venait faire le ménage
ils ont eu quelques mois deux passions
dingue et puis et puis un drame a tout
arrêté
les adultes l'ont été assassiné pour les
cambrioleurs il a été pris en charge par
là par la dass et et puis il est devenu
prof de lettres et son son destin s'est
brisé un jour à cause d'une injustice
terrible qui là qu'il a connu et une
lapidation sur les réseaux sociaux comme
ça arrive si rapidement aujourd'hui
parfois et au lieu d'accepter d'être mis
en disponibilité il a jeté sa des mâts
de l'éducation nationale et a choisi la
dégringolade sociale et cette sorte de
suicide au long cours sur la voie
publique jusqu'au jour où cette fille
qui semble-t-il l'a suivi à retrouver sa
trace et profite de ce moment là de
confinement pour le charger dans la
voiture et lui dire on va laisse
confinés ensemble là d'où on vient et
retourner dans cette propriété à
l'abandon ou
les attend une histoire de
reconstruction peut-être le redémarrage
d'une histoire d'amour et plus encore
sans peut-être dévoiler tout ce qui va
se passer dans le livre l'un sans rien
dévoiler de ce qui va se passer dans le
livre didier van cauwelaert on sent bien
que pour vous cette pandémie a un sens
vous faites partie des gens qui pensent
que on nous envoie un message avec cette
maladie
de toute façon on a intérêt je pense à
penser ça parce que sinon si on se
contente de la fatalité de la peur du
stress de d'accepter que le monde
d'avant soit fini et que le monde
d'après on sait pas quand il viendra
dire il se passe quoi
non il faut réfléchir évidemment
beaucoup de personne d'ailleurs on fait
malgré des conditions d'enfermement
parfois très très difficile on fait ce
chemin chemin simple savoir qu'est ce
qui est l'essentiel
lorsqu'on a perdu la liberté du lien
social à liberté de sortir de faire la
fête
il faut bien trouver d'autres moyens de
de se retrouver soi-même et de retrouver
les autres et on a eu des moments
formidables ces concerts de rue
improvisé d'une fenêtre à l'autre ses
applaudissements de soignants cetc
dévouement extraordinaire on a eu le
pire aussi avec la des lettres de
délation ministère de la santé comme en
avait pas vu depuis l'occupation nazie
mon voisin est d'aller faire ses courses
trop loin il ya les enfants qui jouent
au foot
et puis ces infirmières qui ont trouvé
en entrant chez elles les mots de la
copropriété les priant d'aller habiter
ailleurs bon pas contaminer l'immeuble
donc on a eu tout ça qui évidemment nous
a fait nous a fait avancer
et puis dans le cadre de mon personnage
c'est le moment où tout le monde
s'arrête et on se sent soi même quand on
en a l'occasion quand quelqu'un vient
vous chercher et vient misé sur vous on
se sent une obligation de repartir
et paradoxalement les contraintes on le
sait génère parfois des libertés à
condition de vouloir les prendre à bras
le corps
ne pas le faire uniquement pour soi mais
en l'occurrence peut-être même quasiment
pour l'humanité vous faites allusion à
une déclaration du président ronald
reagan en 1987 disant que nos
différences s'évanouirait si nous avions
à faire à une menace étrangère à la
terre et vous dites qu'il avait ajouté
et encore que je me pose la question
cette force étrangère n'était elle pas
déjà parmi nous il a vraiment dit ça
ronald reagan
ah oui à l'assemblée des nations unies
absolument le discours existe on en a
elles sont le texte et des images et il
est allusion bien sûr abbas ce qu'on a
appris depuis quand tous les dossiers de
l'armée américaine petit à petit
concernant les ovnis et les contacts
divers ont été déclassifiés et alors il
ya eu longtemps
bon bah ya eu il ya eu défaut il ya eu
on a voulu on a fait croire comme c'est
souvent pour détourner l'attention
on a fait prendre au sérieux des choses
qui se sont révélées fausses des
trucages vidéos d'imagés tout et puis et
puis voilà maintenant on en est comme
avec le rapport cometa en france au
pilote qui parle aux mesures
enregistrées par les par les radars ou à
des photos que les laboratoires
militaires ont enregistré et voilà alors
vous faites allusion à ma citation de
reggane parce que eh ben audrey 7
ce premier amour de de l'uqam ont
narrateur lorsqu'elle sent qu'il faut
quelque chose de très fort quand même
pour le réactiver va lui dire quelque
chose d'énorme va lui dire qu'en fait
comme lui et un sdf elle n est une spf
une simple net fixe elle vient
d'ailleurs elle est à l'origine un petit
peu de cette pandémie destinée à donner
une dernière chance à l'humanité alors
lui où il entend ça est complètement
atterrée et se dit mais bon en même
temps autant rester confiné avec une
créature de rêve même si elle est un peu
borderline côté cerveau
mais mais mais ensuite qu'y at il de
vrais de possibles de deux nécessaires
dans ce message là c'est ce qu'on va
découvrir dans le livre vous fait
également allusion un livre intitulé les
yeux des ténèbres un livre signé jean
kunz qui était paru il ya 20 ans 1980 et
dans lequel on
on faisait apparaître à yoann yoannn
comme comme c'est arrivé pour le kevin
19 une une arme biologique
particulièrement contagieuse c'était un
roman mais peut-être que vous y croyez
aussi dur comme fer au monde didier
blanc que blanc
c'est intéressant ce n'était pas la
première édition de de son roman où ça
se passe à one c'est à la seconde
édition pourquoi at il changé
c'est donc pourquoi est-ce que ce roman
rentre dans le cadre de ces six nombreux
travail travaux de fiction qui ont
raconté une réalité avant qu'elle ne se
produise je pense à jules verne ne
donnant exactement de la distance et le
et le trajet qu'on mettrait pour aller
de la terre à la lune
je pense à ces trois écrivains qui
trente ans trois ans et quelques
semaines avant le naufrage du titanic
ont écrit totalement le ce type de
naufrage ce type de navire qui
n'existaient pas donc à l'époque dont le
nom lui-même été approchant je pense à
frédéric dard écrivant dans un roman
l'histoire d'un romancier dans la fille
et kidnappé par quelqu'un qui s'est
faufilé dans une équipe de télé et sur
ce manuscrit sur lequel il travaille est
enfermé dans son tiroir
est ce qu'il est en train d'écrire va
lui arriver un jour et sa fille
joséphine va être enlevé dans des
circonstances qu'il imaginait mêmes et
même cesser le détail que m'avait confié
mon ami frédéric dard le montant de la
rançon qu'il avait écrit dans son livre
c'est celui qu'on lui qu'on lui
demandera donc là est ce que tout ça
n'est que de la coïncidence pourquoi pas
mais elle est un peu énorme
est ce que notre imagination a le
pouvoir d'aller voyager en dehors de
nous pour trôner des idées même des
idées terrible comme ça et funeste à des
personnes ou bien est-ce qu'on capte
quelque chose qui peut se passer dans le
futur je sais pas je sais pas et là
simplement dans tout le scénario 2 2
de ce virus quand il est racontée comme
un scénario évidemment on dirait la
scénario c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible tant de coïncidence n'est pas
possible que ou and do le virus va
s'échapper selon toute vraisemblance
d'un laboratoire très sécurisée de type
p 4 ce soit cette ville et à ce moment
là où va se lancer le lancement mondial
de la 5g c'est la ville test choisi par
les par les chinois et la 5g selon
certaines études qui ne sont pas payés
par les opérateurs
l'un des effets secondaires pourraient
être la perte de l'odorat et du goût
donc si vous voulez on a là dessus des
tas d'interrogations qu'on est en droit
de se poser ça s'appelle l'esprit
critique ça s'appelle pas le complotisme
on est quand même aujourd'hui dans une
époque où on me dit mais fermez votre
gueule et mettez votre masque et
attendait que ça se passe en attendant
le vaccin non c'est pas comme ça qu'un
être humain digne de ce nom fonctionne
il faut vérifier ce qu'on nous dit il
faut être essayé surtout de t'empêcher
que la peur et le stress qui sont ce
qu'ils font baisser le plus les défenses
immunitaires ne prenne le contrôle de
nos vies et de nos sociétés avec tous
les dangers de déviation de dictature
sanitaire qu'on a vu ailleurs dans le
passé qui hélas peuvent toujours être
être une menace de vents doux didier van
cauwelaert moi je croyais accepter vos
personnages qui croyaient à tout cela
notamment au fait que le vaccin va être
rendu obligatoire et va nous inoculer
des puces dans le cerveau s'en extrait
votre personnage c'est pour les besoins
du roman mais je m'aperçois que c'est
vraiment vous y croyez vraiment qu'on a
sorti les noms mais je suis d'un
laboratoire de hann d'un laboratoire p4
ça faisait rentrer dans la tête c'est
pas seulement votre personnage ah non
moi je moi je
d'abord ce sont mes personnages qui
parlent et puis ce sont les
scientifiques qui étudient tout ça c'est
à dire la piste aujourd'hui du pangolin
argent à l est
rejeté par la majorité des spécialistes
jeudi ou bien on est dans une série de
coïncidences vraiment vraiment très très
troublante mais pourquoi pas ou alors
ou alors on cherche on cherche un sens
on s'interroge et et on a atterrés dans
l'histoire l'histoire nous a prouvé qui
a toujours intérêt à s'interroger mais
ce sont ses armes ces anticorps là aussi
que j'ai essayé de transmettre travers
une histoire qui est aussi qui est avant
tout un conte philosophique qui ne donne
pas de réponses qui ne désigne personne
mais qui essaie de de faire remonter nos
anticorps parle par le rêve l'humour et
l'émotion et le chalenge contre qu'on
relève dans ces périodes où on a
l'impression qu'on ne peut plus prendre
de décisions individuelles et qu'il faut
juste obéir mais didier van cauwelaert
que le romancier cherchent un sens on le
comprend bien mais pensez vous qu'il
faille donner un sens à tout un virus
par définition c'est naturel s'il doit y
avoir qu'un sens c'est que la nature est
mauvaise la nature et méchante c'est
bien pour ça que l'homme essaye de la
dante et depuis si longtemps de nom mais
vous avez vous avez tout à fait raison
frédéric il ya toujours eu des virus il
y à chaque année des nouveaux virus des
nouveaux coronavirus il y a eu des
pandémies bien plus grave que celle
qu'on vit aujourd'hui pourquoi c'est la
première fois qu'une pandémie est
scénarisé de la sorte ça la question et
elle ne peut c'est une question que tout
le monde se pose et en particulier les
romanciers les scénaristes qui sont
quand même habitué un petit peu à voir
quand il ya vraiment un travail qui est
à l'oeuvre
et puis le
le trucage des chiffres là aussi tant de
spécialistes aujourd'hui nous explique
que ce qu'on qualifie comme mort du co
vides sont des gens qui sont devant avec
le co vide il ya des exemples et là
c'est absolument indéniable de gens qui
étaient guéris qui ont été écrasé par un
bus et qui sont comptés dans un ehpad et
ça malheureusement je le sais je
traverse qui est arrivé dans ma famille
il suffit qu'il ya eu un cas de co vide
pour qu'une personne qui meurent
d'autres choses soit catalogué victimes
du coc vide ça ce sont des réalités qui
dans lesquels on peut pas fermer les
yeux et puis toute cette politique de
confinement et tout a été décidé en
grande partie en fonction de modèles
informatiques notamment celui de neil
ferguson l'impérial collège université
anglaise qui rappelons nous nous avait
prédit 500 1000 meurent en france et qui
encore plus récemment quand la suède a
décidé de ne pas confiné de ne pas
rendre le masque obligatoire
il a prédit neil ferguson pour le mois
de juin
cent mille morts en suède on en est à
5800 je crois donc c'est monsieur vire
mal c'est un quelqu'un qui fait de la
prédiction magique qui a influencé en
tant que spécialiste incontournable et
décision de la plupart des pays donc là
si on ne marche pas sur la tête et si
les les romanciers sont pas là aussi pau
raconter cette chose qui paraît sortis
de leur imagination mais qui est la
réelle la réalité que nous vivons
aujourd'hui dans toutes ses conséquences
assez pénible ben voilà on passe à peu à
côté je crois de de notre mission ce qui
est la dernière question 10 des ventes
europe
vous dites ce qui est mortifère c'est la
politique d'économies
du dut en matière de santé pour vous au
fond c'est ça le c'est ça le point final
oui et là le plus important
et là c'est pas le romancier qui s'est
pas le romancier qui parle là c'est le
citoyen c'est là c'est l'empathie qs et
voilà le problème il est venu le
confinement franchement se justifier
pour une raison c'était éviter cette
saturation dramatique des hôpitaux
mettre en danger si gravement les
médecins des infirmières et tout ça et
faire des foyers de contamination terry
parce qu'à l'époque rappelons nous on
nous disait le masque il y en a pas mais
de façon ça ne sert à rien donc on a
privé de masques tant de médecins
d'infirmiers a qui ont été contaminées
directement à une époque où vraiment il
c'était nécessaire et alors on aurait pu
croire que la priorité numéro un du
gouvernement était de que ça ne se
reproduise plus jamais un effort
gigantesque un effort de guerre puisque
paraît-il de sommes en guerre contre un
ennemi invisible et virales on pensait
que c'était là l'hôpital et j'entends
l'autre jour quelqu'un demi soeur la
santé dire ah ouais mais on n'a pas le
temps c'est encore des problèmes
aujourd'hui hélas hier encore un chef de
service à l'hôpital saint louis en
cancérologie lundi qu on va être obligé
de retarder toutes les opérations toutes
les interventions vitales pour beaucoup
pour ne laisser la place qu'aux malades
du cog vide actuel ou qu'on attend qu'on
soupçonne par ces modèles modélisation
informatique et ça c'est dramatique et
c'est dégueulasse pour les patients pour
tout ce qu'ils sont et pour tous tous
les soignants et là franchement je ne
comprends pas je ne comprends pas où
c'est très bien de distribuer autant
milliards à des tas de gens qui en ont
besoin mais voilà il me semblait que
c'était réglé du côté de l'hôpital qu'on
avait compris le message
l'inconnue du 17 mars et le nouveau
roman de didier van cauwelaert et c'est
le premier roman en tout cas à ma
connaissance sur le confinement
[Musique]
charles berberian vous publiez une
époque fantastique aux éditions du chêne
ce sont les dessins que vous avez fait
pour le magazine grazia
c'est une chronique de l'époque un
exercice dans lequel se sont illustrés
aussi bien sans paix que claire
bretécher est-ce que c'est difficile
parce qu'on sait bien ce que d'abord
parce qu'on pense à des grands anciens
comme sempé et claire bretécher mais
aussi parce que sous de manière
sous-jacente on sait qu'on doit trouver
illustré raconter la substantifique
moelle d'une époque ce qui la
caractérise au fond au début on se dit
que ça va être difficile ouais je
pensais que j'y arriverai pas
pour toutes ces raisons que vous venez
de d'énumérer bon l'époque est
suffisamment riche en idées il suffit de
regarder autour de soi donc c'est pas
les idées qui manquent s et c'est juste
peut-être le temps où l'énergie et puis
finalement on se retrouve comme un
marathonien c'est à dire une fois qu'on
a trouvé son rythme de travail et son
souffle ça s'installe et c'est plutôt
exaltant de réagir
toutes les semaines un quelque chose qui
nous titille nous angoisse dérange nous
énerve nous amuse et c'est comme ça que
j'ai fonctionné j'ai essayé j'ai trouvé
beaucoup de plaisir si on le comparait
aux nombreux albums de sempé ou aux
nombreuses album de prêter chez on
pourrait dire que il y a plus d'écrans
un sas et alignable défaut car il ya
plus de joker aussi c'est fou ce
concours et puis il ya plus de mots un
oui et garçons alors je je je suis très
attentif a assez assez assez deux
sources qui monte qui monte nourris
qu'ils continuent à mourir je relis
bretécher très très régulièrement et je
lis en paix
toutes les semaines dans paris match et
je trouve absolument fabuleux quoi c'est
vrai que je suis content quand je me
suis lancée dans l'exercice je me suis
dit bon de toute façon je vais pas faire
le malin je marche sur les traces de
sang p2 bretécher et d'ailleurs il ya
une page hommage à bretécher dans le
livre que j'avais publié dans le
hors-série en hommage à cet auteur qui
nous a quittés il ya quelques mois quoi
par exemple dans l'un des derniers
albums de bretèche et il y avait il y
avait ces nouveaux parcs à vélo qu'on
trouve un nombre peu à peu près partout
et que philippe dupuis et moi avions
oublié de dessiner dans dans boboland
quand on s'était lancé dans dans le
portrait de notre génération et des
quartiers dans lesquels on nous vivions
donc j'ai juste essayé de pas ne pas
rater quelques détails importants autour
de moi quoi j'ai après le côté le
troisième point que vous sauviez c'est
le côté homos j'ai l'impression que
c'est plus enfin en tout cas ce que j'ai
essayé de faire c'est de décrire une
sorte de de sexualité qui qui n'a plus
de frontières qui n'a plus de barrières
notamment des genres c'est à dire qu'on
s'aime d'être humain à être humain
et puis bon si ce fait si c'est le même
sexe ou un sexe différent ça passant
c'est un détail avec lequel on fait quoi
mais c'est pas si important que ça quoi
c'est ça que je ressemble dans notre
époque toujours si l'on compare les
personnage de sempé était dépassé par un
monde de plus grand que les personnages
de bretécher était de plus en plus
dépassés par un monde de plus en plus
complexes pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on les
appelait les frustrés et vous j'ai
l'impression que les vôtres ont un
problème différent
au fond le monde était leur disposition
ils ne savent pas quoi choisir est je
crois que ça s'est vraiment à des traits
de notre époque
l'hyper choix on ne sait plus quoi
choisir on peut choisir
on a tous d'où l'idée de revenir à soi à
l'essentiel quand on les y force
notamment grâce à un virus envahissant
soit par goût par exemple musicalement
c'est le règne des tribus des niches
c'est peut-être à cause de la
l'évolution de l'économie du marché du
disque mais mais c'est aussi un goût qui
qui qui est disons peut-être aussi une
question d'exigence je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas se suffire de peu devient
une sorte d'idéal
moi qui aime les livres vous pouvez voir
derrière moi que je ne me suffit pas de
peut donc j'ai pas je sais pas mais
c'est vrai que c'est une question de
choix c'est à dire que par exemple moi
j'ai choisi d'aimer le livre voilà jeu
ce qui m'empêche pas de lire de temps en
temps le journal sur sur une tablette
il faut voir le bon côté des choses de
notre époque c'est à dire que toulouse
est accessible et le mauvais côté c'est
que si on ne choisit pas et finalement
on reste comme des hérissons paralysé
devant des farc qui leur foncent dessus
quoi il faut et faut être acteur a été
moins ça c'est la grande leçon par
exemple des romanciers et pas seulement
enfin des romanciers par exemple j'ai
pas mal ruegg au prat aussi qui fait
aussi partie de mes mes références
probablement très invisible mais mais
mais acteurs et témoins
c'est un peu le rôle aussi du
dessinateur c'est un peu ce que fait
sans psk ce café bretèche et on est
isolé dans notre coin on regarde notre
de loin mais pas de si loin que ça parce
que on continue à vivre à vivre à vivre
une vie normale
on se trimballe
au milieu des gens on s'assoit aux
terrasses de café moi c'est ce qui m'a
le plus manqué pendant le confinement
c'est d'avoir l'occasion de d'observer
de continuer à observer mais mais mais
mes camarades mes concitoyens mais voilà
c'est c'est mais notre époque et elle
est tout et son contraire c'est à dire
que pour la première fois au moment où
ça devenait vraiment facile de se
trimballer à l'autre bout du monde
physiquement et aussi virtuellement eh
bien il ya un choix qui nous a imposé en
ce moment c'est à dire qu'on le on a mis
un frein à au transport physique et du
coup le transport via virtuel ce a
explosé comme mais heureusement que ce
transport virtuel existe puisque on a eu
la possibilité de communiquer avec notre
famille avec nos amis éloignés
donc moi je je je trouve qu'on a
beaucoup de chance
enfin je dis ça et on a l'impression de
est certainement qu'il ya un aspect
cauchemardesque à ce qu'on est en train
de vivre mais mais je peux pas
m'empêcher de voir le bon côté des
choses aussi ce qui est petit pourquoi
ne pas vous avez appelé cet album une à
une époque fantastique
ouais ça vient d'eux de paraître aux
éditions du chêne
[Musique]
clarisse kaplan vous vous jouez
joséphine baker dans joséphine b une
biographie théâtrale écrite et mise en
scène par xavier durringer au théâtre de
la scène française c'est jusqu'au 3
janvier à 19h c'est la première femme
noire à être devenu une star en france
est ce que votre génération lacaunaise
que est-ce que vous connaissiez
joséphine baker est ce que vous en avez
une idée assez précise avant qu'on me
propose ce rôle
non je connaissais déjà joséphine baker
ce que tout le monde connaît c'est à
dire la résistante la danseuse la mère
adoptive
je la connaissais un petit peu parce que
ma grand mère me veut que je lui
ressemble mais pas plus vraiment comme
tout le monde et puis un jour xavier
durringer ma m'a dit tu leur semble je
vais écrire un texte pour toi voilà donc
la premier cadeau de mon premier
spectacle en plus elle a maintenant je
la connais bien et alors ce spectacle la
saa retrace son parcours de sa petite
enfance jusqu'à la mythique danse des
bananes et on a décidé on a décidé de
terminer sur ça de terminer en fait où
tout commence et ensuite les gens
connaissent dans l'inconscient collectif
plus ou moins mais l'orgueil n'a fait
son parcours jusqu'au succès quoi
j'arrive kaplan c'est vrai que vous lui
ressemblez beaucoup et joséphine baker
notamment quand vous êtes coiffé comme
elle en tout cas la coiffure qu'elle
avait au tout début de sa carrière
néanmoins n'avez vous pas peur qu'on
vous reproche de ne pas s'être assez
noir a enfin on me pose cette question
vous êtes le premier j'en suis très
étonné non moi je ne leur reproche pas
d'autant moins qu'elle était en plus à
des métis amérindienne donc joséphine
baker mai mais exactement
voilà mes mais fatalement on peut vous
le reprocher vous le savez bien
ah oui je suis je m'y attends oui
joséphine baker comme vous le disais
c'est une femme métisse a en fait son
père serait si c'est bien son père un
espagnol et sa mère est elle-même métis
amérindiennes et afro américaines
il se trouve que joséphine baker dans
princesse tam tam
elle joue une tunisienne et moi c'est
dans l'origine alors oui bon moi aussi
j'ai en fait je suis métisse alors
est-ce que j'ai plus de 100 noir blanc
ça je ne fais pas mais là le principe
c'est surtout de défendre l'universalité
un but et c'est elle a beaucoup marqué
et et notamment dans ce spectacle vous y
dans ses seins nus comme elle c'est en
partie ce qui l'a rendue célèbre
pourtant on était dans un pays à
l'époque où on avait des danseuses nues
on n'avait pas attendu joséphine baker
il y avait eu les folies bergères je
crois que la première femme le premier
ni intégral c'est à paris aux folies
bergères et c'est en 1912 donc treize
ans avant que arrive joséphine baker
néanmoins
tout le monde va parler de son corps va
parler d'eux c'est ça alors est ce que
c'est parce que c'est le l'arrivée du
corps noir est ce que c'est à cause du
rythme comment vous l'expliquez pourquoi
elle cette fascination pour la nuit dit
et de joséphine baker dans un pays dans
une ville où la nudité date de belle
lurette
oui alors en france oui c'est en france
qu'elle a fait ça mieux parce que aux
états unis je crois que ça serait pas
passé c'est ce que vous disiez sûr que
c'est l'exotisme
c'est la couleur de sa peau sa cambrure
la forme de ses fesses c'est oui ce
rythme cette manière de bouger qui est
un petit peu différente
il faut savoir qu'à paris 1920 après
guerre tout ça il ya une espèce de negro
fils y qui s'est mise en place qui ne
s'était absolument pas le cas aux états
unis et l'afrique est totalement à la
mode à paris c'est vrai à ce moment là
au moment où arrive à la revue
c'est comme ça qu'on l'avait intitulé et
vous avez raison les directeurs du
théâtre des champs-elysées avaient
trouvé le spectacle un peu prude
ils se rendent en rajouter justement
pour que ce soit beaucoup plus pour les
français
parce que les américains évidemment
c'était un autre monde c'est le jazz qui
arrive
iliad joséphine baker mais il ya aussi
sidney bechet pour moi c'est
véritablement là l'arrivée du rythme et
on sait que à l'époque c'était très
difficile de filmer de joséphine baker
parce que s'il est malséant ces images
seconde et on n'arrivait pas à capter
tous les enchaînements dont elle était
capable pour vous j'ai pas si vous êtes
danseuse au départ mais mais il faut le
faire d'un carnet joséphine baker qui
danse c'est quand même un challenge
avait c'était très compliqué au début
parce que j'ai essayé de décortiquer ses
pas pour pouvoir les reproduire
et effectivement avec ses histoires
d'image seconde là impossible impossible
heureusement j'avais une chorégraphe
sublime qui s'appelle florence la vie et
n'ont ni mon ami mon coéquipier ni moi
n'étions danseurs et c'est elle qui nous
a tout appris
en gros ce comédien nous normalement ce
spectacle arrive là au théâtre de la
scène rock parisienne et au même moment
un livre qui sort sur joséphine baker on
sait que le président de la république
fait allusion et joséphine baker quand
il a fait son discours sur les 150 ans
de la république
qu'est-ce qui se passe joséphine baker
j'ai regardé il n'y a pas d'anniversaire
de décence ou de mort pourquoi tout
tombe au même moment pourquoi on est
tous sur joséphine en ce moment alors là
j'ai remarqué la même chose que vous
mais je n'en sais rien je crois quoi
xavier durringer a eu du flair
je crois que cette hausse elle arrive au
bon moment voyez là les gens commencent
à retourner doucement au théâtre on
commence à pouvoir rejouer parce que
joséphine c'est un projet qu'on avait
déjà depuis plus d'un an
et c'est maintenant qu'on peut jouer je
ne sais pas pourquoi il ya cet
engouement autour de cette femme mais
pour moi ça tombe bien on le dit souvent
est là elle a été résistante elle a même
été agent secret pour la france libre
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale on
parle aussi des douze enfants qu'elle a
adoptés ce à la ruine et d'ailleurs elle
avait un grand château dans lequel elle
les a faits vivre elle est morte criblée
de dettes la pauvre en 1975 ce dont on
parle moi c'est de son léopard parce
qu'on parle toujours de ses 12 enfants
mais elle avait aussi un léopard et je
me demande ce qui était le plus
difficile si c'était d'avoir adopté 12
enfants ou à leopard os je crois que
c'est un grand bordel parce qu'il y
avait pas carnet au parent avait des
oiseaux des singes des chats de tout je
crois non mais c'est en même temps
j'admire voyez là fini elle a fini
ruinés mais tout ce qu'elle avait elle a
donné quoi elle a donné son coeur a
donné son ouïe son argent on peut par
son admiration
s'il reste à deux décennies une fois
qu'on a donné son coeur et son argent il
reste que sa vie est dédé merci clarisse
kaplan vous êtes donc au théâtre de la
scène parisienne
tous les soirs dès 19h by the dome
armand way qui jouent le leur et si ton
on va dire et c'est jusqu'au 3 janvier
bonne chance pour la suite
[Musique]
jean-marc ventesde vous êtes le
directeur du festival des voix des lieux
des mondes qui se tient chaque année à
moissac et à la française dans le monde
tant juin bien été reculé au mois de
septembre et au mois d'octobre
du 8 au 11 octobre une première partie a
eu lieu en septembre
alors pour ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas
encore le festival des voix qui a
pourtant près d'un quart de siècle
maintenant petite bande annonce de ceux
qui s'ils devaient s'y produire en
septembre
est ce qui va s'y produire en octobre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le monde
[Musique]
non
là bas c'est le feu là bas et ses fins
ouvre les yeux et de ne la main ouvre la
porte
[Musique]
toutes ses fins
tombé
[Musique]
encore
non mais
mais
[Musique]
là
oui
ok
[Musique]
jean ba cent s envoyer l'abandonna on
comprend un peu ce qui caractérise votre
festival il faut pas être trop blanc 1
joséphine baker il y aurait été invité
tout de suite maurice chevalier
pas sûr si l'important c'était en mai en
valeur quand même les voiles et voix du
monde c'est vrai mais aussi via les
voies aussi européennes blessures qui
sont là mais c'est vrai qu'on essaye
c'est un festival qui est dans le
patrimoine de moissac et de la française
dans des jardins dans le cloître de
moissac ou 6 mai dans des chapelles des
jardins ou dans des châteaux ou d'envoi
on essaye de trouver des endroits un peu
un peu comme ça qui sort of du
patrimoine et on trouve que la musique
du monde est partie de ce patrimoine
aussi donc voilà et c'est vrai que moi
chaque qui est une ville métisse et
viéville du patrimoine
et voilà c'est pour ça que le festival
dure depuis maintenant 24 à l'ajustement
24 ans être directeur d'un festival
c'est être sur la corde raide en
permanence notamment quand il commence
juste un peu avant et quand il commence
ma femme aime le reste de l'année
parce qu'on y pense tout le temps c'est
quoi vos pires souvenirs en tant que
directeur du festival avait le pire
souvenir c'est quand on programme à des
artistes qui ne viennent pas que donc
voilà c'est ce qui se passe avec et
tiken jah fakoly qu'on a vu sur le clip
tiken a tourné à annuler sa tournée la
production parce que tous les festivals
on arrête donc il a fallu le changer au
dernier moment là il ya dhafer youssef
on a failli aussi l'annuler parce qu'il
ya eu problème d'avion et de transport
et il faut qu'il fasse des tests pour
prendre les avions donc c'est en ce sens
du pain serein et c'est très dur et on
est ce qu'on peut dire un petit festival
associatif et tous les autres festivals
sont pris par des des grosses machines
donc nous on se bat dans une ville de
2000 habitants à moissac pour que
suffisent à un festival existe et en ce
moment je suis vraiment pas facile c'est
vrai que en ce moment c'est même en plus
mal vu de se rassembler c'est à dire que
dès qu'on est jeunes dès qu'on prend un
verre
et
si on danse je vous en parle même pas
mais pour peu qu'on écoute en plus de la
musique trop fort en général on peut
déclencher des manifestations en ce
moment donc ça doit être très très dur
là oui parce que toutes les semaines ça
change avec les préfectures donc voilà
il ya eu hier j'ai un trou de la
préfecture donc en pole et on peut
encore aller au spectacle dans des
salles dans des salles fermées les
salles de spectacles et bien sûr avec
des jauges bien réduite
il faut il faut des circuits de pas
rentrer des circuits pour faire pour
sortir ça devienne très compliqué donc
les gens ils ont du mal aussi aller au
spectacle le malheureusement dont il
faut gérer tout ça mais pour nous
c'était important de continuer à ce
festival pour l'économie l'économie de
artistique et l'économie des techniciens
les attachés de presse et tout le monde
et aussi pour l'économie de la ville des
hôtels et tout ça donc c'est pour ça
qu'on s'est battu pour que ce festival
soit reportée et non annulée
tiken jah fakoly il a été remplacé par
fadda freddy je crois et daara j family
voilà exactement une superbe soirée
enfin ils sont là donc qu'ils sont tous
arrivés à paris on est sûr ils seront là
donc là je suis un peu rassuré mais
voilà ça va être une super soirée aussi
de les recevoir
normalement il ya une une inflation du
nombre de festivals pendant l'été en
france mais pas seulement en france dans
toute l'europe maintenant et les plus
vieux festivals français par exemple se
retrouvent en compétition pendant les
mois d'été avec des festivals partout en
europe
donc c'est inflation des prix il devient
de plus en plus difficile d'avoir des
stars parce que tout le monde veut les
mêmes et qu'elles deviennent et comme en
plus elles vendent plus de disques elle
veut se faire payer très très cher ça
doit vous faire très bizarre là vous
vous retrouvez quasiment seul
normalement en juin il ya du monde en
compétition avec vous mais là vous êtes
tout seul
y'a plus personne la vérité serait qu'on
a eu beaucoup de mal à faire une
probation en juin parce que c'est vrai
que tout au tout les festivals essayent
de garder de prendre des artistes et une
concurrence énorme mais une concurrence
mais sur avec les prix qui augmentent et
non l'effet de négocier d'avoir des
artistes mais c'est vrai que là on 7
septembre et octobre du coup
on a le choix tout le monde peut venir
jouer les artistes ils veulent venir
jouer parce que il est dit zhu plein et
joue plus depuis depuis le mois de mars
irma a été là en septembre c'était sa
première scène depuis mars et en plus
son album est sorti en mois de mars elle
devait faire une tournée tout s'est
arrêté quoi donc a été super contente
d'être là ils ont quand même du mal un
peu parce que ils n'ont pas le temps de
répéter de se retrouver avec leurs
musiciens tout ça c'est pas si facile
que ça mais c'est passionnant parce
qu'on retrouve des artistes comme comme
vous et avançant sans grand tournant
autour voilà donc on arrivait à les
avoir
et avec le public ça se passe très très
bien justement elle aussitôt en
septembre il ya eu quatre jours déjà une
première
une première semaine enfin première
séquence on va dire les deuxièmes
ce sera là au mois d'octobre du 8 au 11
comment ça s'est passé en septembre on
était moins flipper qu'on ne l'est
aujourd'hui mais enfin c'était quand
même déjà assez tendue c'est de voir
tout à coup votre festin et que des gens
masqués c'est spécial déjà le masque
était obligatoire n'ont pas encore
peut-être oui oui le masque était
obligatoire dans les salles
oui dans les salons obligatoire même
d'ailleurs à l'extérieur dans le corps
après les gens et au bien de garder le
masque donc c'est pas facile de le faire
comprendre mais bon les gens il ya pas
irhal pas trop il ya toujours un ou deux
paires l'une de personnes on est tous
des français donc et toujours des
personnes qui râlent mais mais ça s'est
très très bien passé et les gens ils
sont vraiment content de sortir donc on
a eu beaucoup beaucoup plus de monde
dans le club passe quand c'est en plein
air donc les gens qui sont venus plus
facilement mais c'est une
du coup la jauge est est passé de 5 2
500 à 300 places donc voila et en salle
dont l'un s'était la tique un peu plus
dur donc la salle qui ne sert de 600
places et et on avait une charge de 400
et on s'est retrouvé à 250 dans la salle
donc c'est très dur à l'économie la de
la billetterie les gens ne sortent pas
tant que ce à quoi il faut il faut qu'il
faut revenir au spectacle mais moi
j'estime qu'il faut il faut démarrer il
faut redémarrer de ce milieu du
spectacle et les gens au fur et à mesure
et vont reprendre l'habitude
le chemin des spectacles et aussi des
cinémas parce que le cinéma c'est pareil
je marque fender je vais poser la
question didier van cauwelaert vous
retournez au spectacle c'est vrai que
les conditions seront pas terrible mais
il faut penser aux artistes privé de
priver de seine si longtemps de publi de
moyens de vivre aussi et c'est important
d'être là aussi même si les conditions
sont pas idéales oui merci
tous les quatre d'avoir participé à
cette émission je rappelle que c'est du
8 au 11 octobre à moissac et à la
française le festival des voix merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]